on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight appears we're gonna censor trust
Jets to Europe for talks and Ukraine
back home into Canada war will benefit
Cuts be the next big u-turn
five years ago the metoo movement sent
shockwaves through Hollywood and across
the world by exposing predatory
treatment of women but is it now harming
young men we'll debate that
for us to have a go Heroes filling the
void left by police Britain's police in
crisis and getting stabbed for their
Trouble Is it safe to take the law into
your own hands
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
and welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
well ladies and gentlemen these are
difficult times for Britain our neediest
people are struggling to keep up with
brutal rises in energy bills rocketing
rents could leave some people homeless
now mortgage rates are exploding too
millions of young people have no hope of
ever owning their own homes without the
bank of mum and dad
Caucasian boys many of them raised in
our most deprived neighborhoods and now
the worst performing demographic for
getting University places and today
Charities are warning the disabled and
handicapped and will be the worst hit by
the government's benefit Cuts fueling
yet another split in his trusses cabinet
meanwhile refugees and economic migrants
continue to cross the channel in small
boats a crisis that Home Secretary
admits is out of control now how did all
that sound to you that the wording I
used
repeatedly though every time you heard a
little Bing what was that about do you
think I'll tell you what it's about
they're all banned words and phrases
that's where we've got to in this
country
they've all just been banned
can't use it
does that make you sad about the state
of our nation
are you offended by the wording I just
used according to the local government
Association you should be should be very
very offended Council workers across the
country have been banned from using
every one of the words that tinged and
plenty of others an 18-page inclusive
language guys says mums and dads who
become birthing parents ladies and
gentlemen should now be everyone in case
people in between feel upset anything
I'm saying here is that people in the
government payroll spent their time and
our money in a cost of living Crisis
coming up with this garbage these are
difficult times for Britain there's an
awful lot for Council workers to be
getting on with offending people by
using words like mum and dad
should not be one of them this is the
tyrannical language police who are
deprived my humble apologies to anyone
offended by the word deprived of Common
Sense
well joining me now associate editor of
the telegraph Christopher hope talk to
uv's International editor Isabel oakshot
and Associated said the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire so would love to see you
Isabel and two kings of the Fleet Street
political pack I'm not sure you're
allowed to call them kings are you they
might because
I'm a republican I don't want to be
exactly and welcome to both of you uh
just to start with that before we get
into the heavier stuff what's going on
with language police now in in an
official capacity we've seen it at NHS
level we've now seen it local government
level why are they all being cowed into
coming up with this nonsensical stuff it
appears but they're not banned you've
just used them it's just in local
government they're looking for a new way
now I think no I wouldn't use more let
me rephrase it why are they assuming
most normal people would be offended but
come on language evolves over over the
decades you have a problem with mums and
dads Mum and Dad I'm all right yeah
Mom and Dad you sound Sunderland songs
yeah well I wouldn't use that no but
it's easy but it makes sense but if
they're looking to try and be more
inclusive let's not who are they let's
not knock them I'll try it Kevin how can
you be inclusive of a tiny number of
people whilst excluding the vast
majority of the vast majority isn't
excluded it's included as well no I
would still use mum and dad right but if
people want to use them what if I'm
offended you can't
there are bigger problems in the world
and you attack you attack the local
government Association saying look
shouldn't you be doing I agree there are
bigger problems because they've taken
all this time and effort out of their
busy working days in a cost of living
crisis
it's well-meaning people yes it is my
problem is I thought my phone was
getting text messages I could not even
turn off I had no idea they're offensive
words at all so I was reading it
perfectly straight and we were doing the
things to remind people later this is
what every one of those things was a
word to pick up on this whole birthing
parents thing is that not offensive to
people who are adopted who've adopted
their children
I used to get on a plane and I used to
love the moment when they said ladies
and gentlemen was your captain speaking
you're not allowed to say it anymore I
think it might just get ignored
do you three not realize the
contradiction of getting upset other
people get upset then you're getting
upset yourself
because what we're trying to do is
protect is protect language for the vast
majority of people who have no problem
with that language and my past majority
I mean 98 of the world's population
peers we're about to see image you know
that some of the language that would
have been used about gay people people
of color yeah uh when we were kids and
young really I think it's definitely
different yeah but you move on no no
racist and derogatory or homophobic or
transphobic phraseology I'm completely
with you right you should never
stigmatize groups of people right but
changing mums and dads to birthing
parents is actually grotesquely
offensive to every mum and dad who wants
to be called a mum and dad or disabled
people are older people language look
they're trying they're trying their best
once you give an English on this stuff
it never stops now now you've given the
inches we've just said you're given
inches already and in fact miles I'm
glad to say on gay people on people of
color elderly people disabled people and
so there are other people for Christmas
yeah and that's that's right in the
corner
[Music]
let's turn to more serious things Liz
trusts your daily telegraphs big
political Guru
um is there any defense you can put up
which doesn't constitute my belief that
it was like the whole week was a total
disaster she tried to run before she
could walk they were too quick on it
that she was a tax cutting Tory she
basically had an idea about a very good
idea about uh dealing with the energy
bill crisis that was a good idea then I
pumped onto this let's call it a
Christmas tree they attached tinsel uh
Bankers bonuses 45p tax rate stamp Duty
measures and other other things and I
almost killed over as a result oh wait
and that's a problem but as a result of
this this is the problem I have with it
they keep banging on about we did all
this for your energy bills but now the
mortgage bills are going to dwarf energy
bills and of course some of the blame is
that of that is from the international
markets but I'm afraid to say that that
increase in interest rates coming soon
will be blamed squarely on time and Liz
trust it's not all over for them but
it's a really bad start but don't
you think falling the way she acts
absolutely hung her own Chancellor out
to dry yeah
her team say that was her saying it's
quasi's budget it's not much by the way
what a leader does when they want
nothing to do with it yeah and it also
it just isn't true I happen to know that
it was her that was pushing for the time
scale on the 45 people not him so my
issue with it Kevin is it seemed to me
they were playing casino politics with
the nation's economy they were basically
rolling the dice they think we've got
two years to the next election we've got
to move on with this every second counts
we're going to throw the kitchen sink
out there or on the roulette where we're
going to put it all on bread and we're
gonna hope it comes up and maybe it's a
50 50 shot at best and it's come up the
wrong way immediately I mean I've never
seen anything quite like it where the
there's a run on the on the pound the
bank of England steps in with billions
of pounds to bail out to help the
Pension funds not go under we've seen
mortgage companies withdrawing hundreds
of mortgage offers because they can't
actually work out what's going on this
is catastrophic oh absolutely it's
catastrophic for you know just about
everybody in the street because they
will pay the price ultimately normally a
new lead our new prime minister you get
a honeymoon she's gone straight to
divorce and I think it's probably over
for a now I I think
if the lady is for turning and backs off
on her threat to cut the inquiry to the
lowest paid there's no phrasing
universities there's no threat I mean
what will happen
in November when the markets have calmed
down they have got two years the next
election green shoots can happen if if
she is tied to the future of the war in
Ukraine if that uh ends or gets towards
ending and if the engine prices fall
then I think the the growing economy if
this works well you know if you're a
political historian of some reviews
um 81 yeah I keep being 81 right I keep
being told this is mini Thatcher in
action there's trust but thatcher did
the opposite when she first came in it
was a rough old economy she stabilized
the economy she's even put some taxis up
she had a windfall all tax energy
companies she got inflation down she got
the economy stable again and then she
cut income tax dramatically and became
known as a great tax cutter conservative
leader but she did it the right way this
trust has gone in with a worse economy
and you know pretending to be Margaret
Thatcher she's done the actually what I
think would be the opposite of what
Thatcher would have done there is no
time to do what actually done which
would wait to bring it back into line
she had to act quickly like that mini
budget was no time for her personally
for the party that that many budget that
was an election budget they admit the 60
billion billions and they cut taxes
right exactly so here's my point with
that she had no mandate from the country
to do what she did right she had a
mandate of 160 000 conservative parties
maybe a few of them because because
so say a hundred thousand right it's a
hundred thousand people determined that
they're going to put list trust there
and she's going to do this unbelievably
radical as it turned out Reckless mini
budget which nearly paralyzes our
economy instantly and my point about
that is if you don't have a mandate to
do that and you're really doing it for
political expediency for yourself and
your party because you've only got two
years left of the election that I'm
sorry that is they had to be selfish
politics it's a big problem they have
been battered by events uh over the
cover crisis Ukraine you're laughing
he's a big it's a big one let me finish
the Queen's death I've just been the
apologists everything into into a couple
of years I said 81 to you because they
are telling me that they think 1981 is
where the party is now in the sense that
in the sense that the STP were 30 points
ahead and they pulled it back in two
years because of the gray economy and
the four well eventually
sound you're sounding like the lad nil
at the cross at the end of Life of Brian
who's singing all look on the bright
side of life
you've got it absolutely wrong and she
got it she got it wrong because she won
a contest in the cult the conservative I
think there's a bigger Point she didn't
start governing for the country she was
still governing for the country I
totally agree and I and here's the
problem with with this culture now you
know anyone who doesn't agree with her
is anti-growth apparently which is
ironic given how little they've done the
actual growth in the last week right but
I think it's about the bigger problem
for Liz truss she made the mistake Boris
Johnson made came in as prime minister
got rid of every alternative voice she
just surrounded herself bye
smart people go and all these guys
absolutely goes to the heart of it now
so they're all on the outside of a
technique he was on first go he wasn't
sacked I know but she could have brought
go back right I think you would have
came he was said I'm not about to spend
on politics I know what he said I
haven't been a word any of them my point
being if you come in and you just do a
clean swoop of all the negative voices
100 that she is now got her biggest
problem immediately is not actually the
electorate because she's got another two
years it is actually managing the
absolute mess that there is that's
within the Parliamentary party and it
was only that that meant that she did
not press ahead right with the 45 Peter
40 it wasn't the outcry in the country
which is
the problem is Christopher once the
rebels outside know that she has done a
u-turn on one big thing 100 they know
she's a woman who is fraternity right
yes she's a Weathervane did you use that
music
paralyzing for a prime minister she was
called a lame duck leader but bye-bye
Rebels I spoke to at the Party
Conference but it's all about for me
it's all about Tuesday Tuesday is the
day she says sorry to NPS remember MP's
on the right who have bruised about
going out to defending a a an abolished
tax cut those who were sacked than the
29 intake always angry about something
else the left everyone's CrossFit
they're all these factions unite them
say sorry move on
say I get it
before we before we leave this I just
want an extraordinary clip which was a
nurse I think it was the Jeremy Vine
show in the audience a nurse who said
this
there are no resources and you are told
persistently on the news that you know
Care Homes are being ring fenced it's
it's a lie and I'm sorry but if you have
voted conservative you do not deserve to
be resuscitated by the NHS
hang on
I mean I can barely believe what I was
hearing this thing went viral that is a
a British nurse saying that if you are a
conservative voter
you do not deserve to be resuscitated I
think I mean can we all agree this was I
mean I know you don't like Tories but no
no she is she expressing the frustration
that many people can't defend that no I
know she was over the top but she's at
the top he was disgraceful if she's
working in the NHS
that sees the pressure and she knows
what happens with patient no she
shouldn't have said it and and expressed
it like that that is absolutely right
that's it that's where you started
you have dealt with patients being stuck
on trolleys in corridors because you
don't have beds and you haven't got the
care you will feel frustrated
I mean just ridiculous
no I just thought I thought it was a
really despicable thing to say actually
and I was shocked it came out of the
mouth of a nurse yeah because you just
said well you go into nursing not
because of people's political persuasion
you go in to save people of all
Persuasions nurses are caring but Kevin
because of that when she says
can you imagine by the way it could have
been a yeah
anyone voted labor I wouldn't save their
life
your spleen would be exploded yes if you
if you if somebody had said that the end
of the labor period and they're having
trouble spending on the energy
hospitals and maybe there would have
been measurably more horrible but maybe
because of Labor's record on the NHS and
it was so much better there wouldn't be
a nurse who would have wanted to say
that sadly we have to leave you you're
coming back a little later I think
Christopher letting you go I think oh
this is great are we I think we are the
community
a lot of moving around the chairs today
but next to nice five years since the
first Revelations about Harvey Weinstein
and the launch of the metoo movement but
has it now done more harm than good plus
Megan Harry the Royal Fuller of our age
we've got the author of an explosive new
book with Insider details at Rock The
Palace Valentine low from the times the
man who really knows what's going on
behind the burgundy cuts
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to peers organ sense the
Revelation is about disgraced movie
director Harvey Weinstein's abusive
women sparked a global Reckoning with
predatory male Behavior but five years
on from what became known as the metoo
movement there's a growing backlash some
influential people argues become
divisive pretty mistakes is against each
other with an assumption of male guilt
leaving many young men feeling
marginalized reasoning to be two people
the Forefront of that backlash albeit
with very different styles of rationales
he's psychologist Dr Jordan Peterson
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
in the early this week I suppose to
Andrew Tate the so-called toxic male
influences now banned from social media
the full explosive interviewers tomorrow
night but here's a little taster of that
I believe that confident strong man who
stand up and protect and provide for
women are a good thing for the world and
a good Force for the world and I don't
think that I put a magic spell on
anybody I think there's a whole bunch of
men in the world who understands my
value and if if men grow up to be like
me you're gonna have a whole bunch of
people with no criminal record dedicated
athletes who protect and provide for the
people close to them are fantastic for
the economy and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers
well clips of both of those interviews
have exploded online literally millions
of people have been viewing them uh
Jordan Peterson for example the whole
interview has been viewed five and a
half million times on our YouTube
channels rightly or wrongly there's
clearly a huge Groundswell of of
interest at the very least in their
views if not support so it was me too an
overdue Reckoning or has it become a
damaging battle in a raging culture War
Isabel still with me political
journalist Ava 17 and conservative
compensated a young man who agrees with
Peterson and Andrew take Connor Thomas
and Connor uh welcome to the show start
with you
I found it very interesting interviewing
Jordan Peterson Andrew Tate both very
controversial characters in different
ways uh both positioned as a kind of
kings of toxic masculinity I certainly
didn't think Jordan Peterson was that
and when it came to Andrew Tate I
couldn't really conclude after 90
minutes of grilling him I gave him quite
a hard time
um I couldn't really conclude what he
had done that was so bad that he had to
be expunged from social media life
altogether but it showed me the
sensitivity around all this and if any
man now behaves in a way that looks like
his toxic masculinity bang they're
expunged is in that process masculinity
itself getting expunged and demonized I
would say so I mean I'm sure that that
you'll have this experience with your
own relationships peers and that women
if you say something controversial
whether it's uh something on the piece
inside the Spectrum or on the tape side
of the spectrum a little bit more
explosive or a little bit more academic
some women are very much drawn to a man
who can be a bit more confrontational
say exactly what he thinks it's the
verbal new version of what Gladiators
used to do in the arena way back well
certainly I think Ava and Isabel love
him because they know that they're drawn
to me in that way because of my
combative nature but Ava you're smirking
and laughing I mean there's a serious
point a lot of young men feel they're
getting disenfranchised by Society
they're all being over demonized that
any attempt to be the traditional male
figure is now being rubbished and and
called toxic well I mean if you really
felt that and you really went out there
and you weren't alpha male then you
wouldn't be bothered about a bunch of
women telling you that you were
like Andrew if you get banned from it I
mean it can't be been canceled he was on
your program which is on National
Television but it's the only platform
actually he's had for a long time
because all the social media companies
banned him literally banned him he had
his email gone his Google gone his
Facebook gone it's it all went down like
dominoes well he's still on there very
very prolific on there I can't move the
clips yeah but they're not generated by
him now well but that's been for quite
something but should he be published
that way but what it what is what is
punished what it's punished it's where
companies take a decision which in my
view in this case was perverse because
they still allow for example the
Ayatollah of Iran to have Twitter
account yes so there's a there's no
consistency here at all well but however
we love a bit of free market I'm sure
you do judging by that suit which is
lovely
um but you know social media companies
are private companies
but over your point about you know if if
men were that Alpha then they wouldn't
be that bothered by this doesn't really
help us when it comes to boys growing up
and that is one of my worries that for
teenage boys now they are so terrified
of the uh consequences of putting a foot
out of line it was hard enough being a
young teenager working out how things
are working out how to do dating and all
of that without the terror that if you
touch in the wrong place at the wrong
time you may find that your whole life
is destroyed too much well I I like that
I don't like it is I think that men
should be frightened I think you feel
better
with but we're talking about yeah but
we're not talking about we're not
talking about it's an interesting thing
that you see I would say that that
attitude actually is part of the problem
too that is that's to me toxic
femininity that is saying you should all
be terrified you men if you put one
assaulting well I I I think we all
understand what sex life is what
Isabelle's talking about is that young
teenage clums in this in many cases
which is now being re-categorized as
assault is that a problem not being
re-categorized as a soul it's always
been assault it's just we're finally
talking about I don't agree with that
it's ridiculous teenage boy fumbling
with teenage girls in most cases assault
do you remember Aziz I'm sorry right
half the heels of me too half the heels
of Harvey Weinstein rightly being
dragged through the courts and he should
have got way worse than just prison time
in my opinion Aziz Ansari had a
consensual relationship with a woman she
felt a bit awkward and afterwards
rescinded consent and he was London and
he had his voice
even why should men be afraid of that
because he didn't touch her without
consent did he nobody
supposed to navigate this the whole
thing I'm thinking of my teenage son you
know he's 14 15. what's he supposed to
say would you mind if I'm Isabelle you
are an extremely strong woman I know in
your house you're teaching them the
difference between assault and then of
course but what we're talking about is
it's been very interesting watching the
metoo movement and the time's up
movement how it's all developed because
a lot of very bad people Harvey
Weinstein and others got their due
comeuppance we can all agree with that
yeah this is not even something to be
debated we're really talking about the
Gray Line right where is that Gray Line
how do you navigate it when you're an
experienced adult and you've been around
the block in many ways you can navigate
that much more intelligently and with
emotional intelligence then you can if
you're a teenage boy and I think the
point Isabelle makes is a good one I've
had three sons in their 20s I've always
taught them to be respectful to women I
believe they are but I do think it's
really hard for a 16 17 year old boy now
in this environment to know even how to
stop having found some kind of physical
relationship with a woman those good
boys are all terrified I know that from
talking to my son he's just like I'm
just not going there is that healthy yes
I think it is actually I think it's
better to not have a physical
relationship than to have one that could
ruin a woman's life but then how do they
ever start well don't if you're not 100
sure we're gonna have a bunch of Newton
Boys we actually do have that gen Z is
having far less sexual relationships
it's true and young people have stopped
having sex I agree with the first part
of your sentence actually if you're not
willing to have a sexual relationship
with clearly defined lines don't have
one and so I actually told my my mates
at University don't sleep around with
girls one girls don't bring a guy home
that you don't know is capable of two
guys don't bring a girl home if you
think that possibly she could have a
false accusation against you can I make
another Point here which I find I mean
look that sentence to me when I was your
age right how old are you uh 23 23. when
I was your age the idea you would even
have that sort of thought process yeah I
wouldn't have those sort of mates that
would ever cross
is there a certain is there a certain
Purity here I'm detecting in a certain
type of feminist who thinks that they're
all unimpeachable and this is all
one-way traffic and the only men can be
toxic no because I gotta I've got to
Enlighten you I've met quite a few women
in my life who are pretty toxic
themselves and I don't see the debate
being framed around that at all but the
point is is that we're still in a
situation where only five percent of
rape cases actually even go to Trump
which is ridiculous that's the extreme
end of it yeah there's an idea you're
talking about I'm talking about but even
we can all agree that's wrong we can all
agree that's wrong okay so even on the
extreme end of it rape doesn't even go
to trial if you if you're assaulted and
that is life-changing what happened to
Rose McGowan yes with Harvey I know Rose
one
and she didn't get her come up we'd all
agree about that well I think what what
a certainly shudder through all of our
spines from your mouth today is the line
that all young men should be terrified
of any physical contact well no you
didn't say
on something completely
if you were going to go if you were
going to take someone to bed and you
weren't 100 sure that they wanted to go
to bed with you would you go no I would
not do that and the point was disease
and sorry was Shaw for example and then
later she went and published a long
piece as she regretted it and lumped him
in with Harvey once I mean do you feel
do you think any of it Ava's gone too
far do you think the pendulum has gone
too far at all no no I don't think it's
gone far enough actually really I still
I don't think we've brought anything
into schools to your point we haven't
brought any teaching into school about
what is assault what isn't if you're
worried about like 16 year old boys not
understanding what it is bring in sexual
health lessons the idea sorry the idea
that you can teach rapists not to rape
is insane because they already know what
do you mean okay right you're saying if
boys wouldn't know what's assault and
what is yeah right okay the idea that
rather than
um taking the power out of someone who
can make a full accusation is what they
actually most of them are concerned
about specifically my friends for
example who would never dream of doing
something like that but then what the
feminist fail to understand is you can
educate the evils did you not identify
yourself as a feminist
[Laughter]
but you cannot if a rapist is willing to
violate the law so violently you cannot
teach him out of that all you can have
is very harsh punishments to determine
because you're talking about the Gray
Line and the gray line is that parties
of not understanding that when a woman
is so inebriated that she can't stand up
boys need to understand that is well
that's the difference in something else
Ava I would like to know whether you
accept that women and particularly
teenage girls and young women sometimes
give out pretty mixed signals they give
out mixed messages they're not even sure
what they want at any given time I think
we're victim blaming
for every single of your body knows what
she just said so women can sometimes
messages come on I mean sure I'm sure
but I'm talking about a song so how are
you supposed I don't think any of us
disagree about assault we're talking
about the far grayer line of young
teenage fumblers
they've all stopped having sex because
they are actually terrified and I think
it's a great shame if they're terrified
into actually having no physical
interaction with exactly
because I make one other point which is
this whole thing of dredging up
allegations that are 10 or 20 years old
I think is absolutely awful because it's
a he said she said it's impossible to
prove and there are people whose careers
are and their lives are completely
ruined by allegations that are bought a
decade or more after the event now
obviously if the person was a minor at
the time of the incident of the alleged
incident
that we should bring up historic assault
claims I don't think so I don't think
you should be bringing women who would
have been too afraid to confront it at
the time if they were too young or too
powerless
I would actually say slightly with over
here in the sense I don't have a problem
with historic crimes for example Harvey
wisely they're all historically
or should the victims who were all
bullied and scared I think it's to come
forward right I think it depends on the
severity of the allegation obviously if
it's something you know it's a rape case
or something but if it is a you know he
puts it is you're talking about the
journalist movement I'm the journalist
that bravely came forward and told about
how cabinet ministers that touched them
in appropriately on me which was
horrendous
touching on a knee I mean what 20 years
later yeah someone should be she dragged
through the courts for the sexual
harassment culture that is in
Westminster and is still really
pervasive at the moment well the good
thing is we're of always complete
agreement after five years but it's it's
interesting isn't it so we've got lots
of different views here it is
complicated I think and I I would I
would argue but maybe a man shouldn't
argue this at all but I would argue the
pendulum may have swung a little too far
you don't think it's swung far enough
you probably are on my side you probably
are so but I'm not sure we should really
be taking sides either it's a complex
Minefield and I think that the when you
start using phrases you should be
terrified nobody should be terrified on
any side of this I don't think unless
they have a Criminal Intent uh but good
debate thank you very much for coming in
we appreciate it uh you can see more of
my exclusive interview with Andrew Tate
here tomorrow at 8. um you may hate him
you might like him you might love to
hate him I tell you what it's compelling
the interview and it'll be on tomorrow
night
I believe that me standing up and saying
a man must protect the woman and provide
for her so we need to make sure that
she's safe he needs a degree of
authority I have no problem with no but
no you but people do have a problem with
it and that's the word we're in now I'm
over here why are you single I'm not
single well you're not married well if I
was married the last thing I would do is
advertise it to the feral Psychopaths on
the internet so I came back good so we
agree no we don't yes we do no we don't
fears are on my side afraid of being
canceled along with me being empty any
woman at all not when I'm not what I'm
saying that women are beautiful and
attractive at a certain age and if you
fix the problem in their life perhaps
they won't feel the person no but it's
not a disease but Andrew that situation
Andrew it's simply wrong why do you miss
votes no because you're saying being
misplaced that's not the question cheers
hand I believe
like a politician
it's compelling television it's tomorrow
night eight o'clock Andrew Tate the
interview that's already ripping up the
internet well next tonight I'm joined
live by the Royal author who discovered
Harry and Megan was so awful to work for
that former aides Now call themselves
The Sussex survivors Club no really I
met hard to believe and Valentine Lowe
will be here plus after three people
were stabbed in London today trying to
stop a thief on a motorbike I'll be
asking is it ever safe to take the law
into your own hands and why should we
have to we're the police
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to get an explosive new
book courtiers by Valentine low explores
the secret details of the royal Rift
between Harry and Megan and the rest of
the royal family well the author of
Norcross product at the Times Valentine
low is here welcome to you and Isabelle
and Kevin are still with me
um but congratulations a riveting read
thank you absolutely loved it uh full of
juicy gossip you've made a great tabloid
hack uh truly wasted on the times
um very interesting sort of perspective
coming through from it one it looked
like Harry and Megan were a bit of a
nightmare to work for reducing lots of
people to tears and all the rest of it
we knew a bit of that before actually
from you
um but also you're not completely
unsympathetic to Meghan Markle coming
into the Royal firm and encountering the
monarchy and all its good and bad guises
no I mean and what happened when when
she arrived people went out of their way
to help her I mean she had a meeting
with a guy called Miguel head who was
Williams private secretary and he said
listen you're coming you're you've had a
career you're an actress you're growing
up woman you're not you know a new bride
like Diana was
we're here to say you we don't have to
do things the old way
you couldn't carry on acting if you want
you can work in the industry but if you
want you know let's let's there's no
fixed way we're not the Palace of 20 or
30 years so what went wrong
uh I think that she uh was is a piece of
work
that's one of the words in your mouth
that's one way of putting it I I think
what she what you have to realize is
that Harry was already having problems
with working with within the institution
right so he was looking for a way out
anyway I think I think so he he had a
hatred of the media great distrust yeah
which goes back to how his mother died
and everything else yeah and it's
completely understandable yeah um he
also had a mistrust of the coaches and
the other households in [ __ ] Palace
and did it was he right to have a
mistrust are they all a bit duplicitous
in there uh I don't think they're
duplicitous but they may have different
ideas about how to work than from what
he does and also he had this thing about
his shelf life he knew that as he Grew
Older he got less important he gets
important yeah Prince George would grow
up by the time George would be 18 Harry
thought he'd be over and he was obsessed
with trying to have instant results
which is why you know where he invented
Invictus games he did that in a real
hurry yeah from a year uh from seeing
the Warrior games what is going to
happen if his book comes out and it as
people fear in the palace because I've
spoken to some of them it trashes
Camilla the queen as she knows in fact
he's been a directive not to call a
queen consort now but a call of the
queen
and it trashes the queen and it has a go
at his father now the king
is there going to be a Tipping Point for
Charles which the Queen the late Queen
was not prepared to to act on where they
basically he says enough you're losing
all your titles and you can go off and
be Harry and Megan celebrities in
California but you don't have any Royal
titles any Royal status it's over I
don't think that would ever happen I
don't think uh whatever Harry does I
don't think Charles would do that to his
son it's about it's a mess I mean you
hear you've got you know that these two
boys William and Harry who were the
Nations you know beloved young men when
they had to the harrowing thing walking
behind their mother's coffin obviously
horrific the mother was 36. you can't
fail but have sympathy for them but
William's gone one way dealing with it
into duty and all the you know his
country and all the rest of it Harry
disappeared off is there a solution to
this or are we just going to be reading
drama about this for the next 10 years I
mean I think we'd still forgive him you
know I think there is a huge which way
if she's involved residual effects in
there still for Harry and I think it's
very easy to make her the kind of
scapegoat for all of it and he is
absolutely responsible as much as she is
for where things have landed but I think
we could forgive him if he came back and
if she played the game and it was
interesting what you said about you know
the the palace initially saying that you
know she could do things differently
I mean I think there's some appetite for
that but I think in order to get to that
level of national forgiveness she would
have to be seen to do a Kate for quite a
while right I mean you don't even want a
monarchy so you're probably the last
person to ask on this but we are we have
one we have a new king and at the center
of this Kevin is a human drama there is
which is which is very real these two
boys don't talk to each other they
pretty much hate each other the wives
have got involved it's a classic family
dispute let's just reduce it to that
what do you think is going to happen oh
look I mean this family you can imagine
them on Shameless but they've just got
you know footman and butlers if they
lived on accountable
counselor State rather than Country
Estates they'd be known as Social
Services I mean they are totally
dysfunctional this family and it's
before we mention Andrew but there is a
human tragedy there because two brothers
who were very close of falling out um
but I quite admire Harry for wanting to
get out but he wants it both ways yeah
he was that's my problem it was moaning
his dad wouldn't give him the king now
wouldn't give him any more money and
also he's taken that Sussex title which
opens doors for them but if he wasn't a
royal what would he be doing I mean look
I'm from Sussex I've spent more time in
such things than Megan and Harry had in
the last two weeks so actually a month
but um they're never there but they've
got these titles which are given to them
that's what I do what I mean about they
trade off Duke and Duchess of Sussex the
Royals to make themselves incredibly
rich and I just I do wonder if there's a
point where Charles goes actually you
can't do that anymore it'd be
unprecedented but why wouldn't he yeah
but I think it's kind of irrelevant I
mean no one really cares about the
titles uh if you strip them with the
titles there's still Harry and Megan
they'd still be equally famous but they
wouldn't be acting as members of the
royal family yeah I don't think they go
around acting as members of the role
they do all the paperwork all the letter
headings it's all from the office of the
Duchess of Sussex almost nonsense she
calls herself a princess on her podcast
little girls have got to make a real
princess you're not a princess she's not
princess anyway but they do it quite
deliberately to fuel the interest from
commercial entities and really the
interest is based on them trashing their
family I mean without that I'm not sure
what we're interested in we don't hear
their woke homilies about life do we so
I'm not sure how this all plays out but
it's a mess and Charles may have to deal
with it I think it certainly is a mess
uh and I think the the work humble is
have a market in the states that they
don't have here yeah
um and the trash in the royal family
even in the states people begin to get
bored of that I think failed how did you
say I'm fascinated how does it end this
what what is your like your prediction
uh I think he's going to come back here
tail between legs and she'll be she'll
be left there that that will I guarantee
that will never happen for one very
particular reason the kids those kids
are going to stay in the United States
Harry love loves those kids a bit he's a
great father I'm convinced that because
he's always been terrific for children
um so while while she has breath in her
body those those kids Remain the states
and that's what Harry will too well it's
fascinating stuff Valentine it's a
brilliant book I highly recommend it
it's called courtiers the hidden power
behind the crown Valentine low from the
times thank you very much for coming in
thank you Isabel Kevin great to see you
first time since Good Morning Britain
days you look a bit you look a bit more
presentable this other night you do
first so the first thing is a bit of the
horror story don't we all don't we all
know actually you're coming back and
there's been jealous you're not going
anywhere yet
um and next time policing in crisis of
Vigilantes now a grim fact of life in
Britain
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to physical glasses with
almost half of British people saying
they've never seen police on patrol it's
perhaps no surprise that more people are
taking the Law into their own hands this
woman in East London confronted a
would-be robber in a shop tackling the
thug and shoving him towards the door
early this week a mobile phone Thief was
rugby tackled by another public for a
woman choke holds him Heroes for sure
what would potentially dangerous
consequences today three people were
stabbed in London Reports say members of
the public were trying to stop a thief
on a motorbike so should we ever take
policing matters into our own house do
we have any choice if there aren't
enough police around to do it for us
joining me to discuss this is security
and Terror expert will get his and
former Scotland detective Peter black
seed Peter well good to see you both
Peter we'll start with you
my feeling about this some of these
stats I'm really more than a third of
the public so dissatisfied with the
police the highest figure for a decade
official figures published and generally
show that fewer than one in 25 thefts is
solved half the rate of five years ago I
also read today that in England and
Wales only one in six crimes including
murder rape and gbh involving a knife
remain get solved so five out of six
don't get solved when you see stats like
that it's no wonder to me that people
are starting to get a bit more vigilante
because they think well what else am I
going to do policing is in crisis
violent crime is on the rise and we're
all a bit less safe than we were some
years ago it is no surprise that when
people see crime being committed some
people want to get involved they want to
do their bits why is it getting like
this well because people are exasperated
by what they see as the failings of the
police and the criminal justice system
and people go you know what I've had
enough I'm gonna ever go well that's
fine but you really do need to know what
you're doing because the greatest
problem is that you can sometimes make a
bad situation even worse well we saw
today you know a theft was was taking
place and a couple of people on bikes
and three people got stabbed the the
people the the involved in the stabbing
they've disappeared that is I guess a
form of public vigilantism which whether
people have been injured badly perhaps
yeah I mean but I think as Peter was
saying people are feeling the pressure I
mean I know at least half a dozen people
personally who've had their watches
ripped off their arms or been robbed for
their phones or whatever and certainly
statistically we are going into a very
very dark territory I mean uh robberies
of phones have gone up by 60 in the last
year there's 39 000 robberies and thefts
which have occurred in the last 12
months people are fed up with it um and
they believe and they want to please
nothing will get done like I'm the first
to always back the police I think
they're massively understaffed
under-resourced there aren't enough
police on the streets I felt this yeah
twenty thousand coppers off the off the
beat I just it was a catastrophic error
and there's also the question there's no
Community Support policing so I mean in
the same way you don't see police
patrols that often what is not helping
what is aggravating the situation is
that you'll see stop oil protesters and
you'll see some 15 or 20 police officers
attended to that and the way that the
general public will look at it is
they'll go you've got 15 20 officers
dealing with what is a passive albeit
irritating and inconvenient protest why
aren't these officers in our
neighborhoods right and Peter I mean
there are lots of factors Behind Rising
crime I think increased drug abuse is
probably one of them because that
inspires drug gangs and so on
um what is it behind in particular knife
crime that is exploding as well what is
driving that do you think is it the fact
they don't think they're going to get
caught it's a great question that there
is an aspect of that because people will
walk around the corner and not bump into
a police officer these days because
patrolling the streets has been
surrendered by the police unfortunately
um and of course it why do people when
before they leave their homes go right
where's Mickey where's my phone where's
the knife we've got to tackle that
mentality and we've got to stop people
taking knives out onto the streets
because as today is clearly shown there
is a a tighter blood running through the
streets of many of us in America with
the guns for example the argument they
use for why somebody want to carry a gun
is because not because they want to use
it they want to defend themselves
against a lot of other people who've got
guns it's why you see so many police
shootings in America because the police
always believe that everyone they stop
may have a gun on them right we're
heading that way with knives yeah but so
many young people who get captured with
knives will say well others have knives
so I thought I'd better take one out
onto the streets myself well either to
be part of the gang or to defend
themselves yeah and the stats
overwhelmingly show that if you take the
knife out onto the streets you are far
more likely to become a victim of knife
crime yourself I think in some ways
appears it's almost simpler than that a
lot of these Street rats who are going
out and robbing people know that if they
produce a knife they're less likely to
meet any kind of resistance you know
when I teach people in personal
protection one of the things I always
say is these guys are fundamentally cows
they rarely operate on their own they
will operate in gangs one of the big
telltales which people have to be very
very conscious to is that many many
situations are now being launched by on
electric bicycles because obviously
there's no identifiers no number plate
which is easy obviously to trace and
secondly they're all wearing face masks
now maybe two years ago when we were in
the height of the covid pandemic that
would make sense but these days how many
people do we actually see wearing face
masks and most these guys trying to
conceal it but most of them are cowards
and they will simply try and Bully their
way through numbers and so and also the
threat of weapons Peter what's the
answer if you're Liz trusts and you've
come and you've got a basket case of
issues to deal with but what is the
answer about this Rising tide of crime
and the apparent ineffectiveness of the
police in dealing with it give the
police services the number of officers
they need train them properly but make
sure that senior officers take sight of
what is the core principles of policing
not mucking about trying to be Community
engaged with every minority group that
exists in the land stick to the Robert
peel principle that were written nearly
200 years ago and are as relevant and as
apt today as they were back then keep
the streets safe investigate crime when
it happens and catch the bad people
Peter well thank you very much
appreciate you both coming in this
information tomorrow 8 P.M for my pretty
hot hour long interview with Andrew Tate
we don't know much about him you will
afterwards don't miss that 8 o'clock
tomorrow whatever you're up to make sure
it's uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years in Fleet Street
there's loads of stories I could tell
you but actually I think I did an
overnight show for Tool radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking
um the remain had won and at half past
two quarter three after Nigel farage had
already said he'd lost it turned out he
hadn't lost but it turned out we were
leaving the European Union so that was
quite a shocking
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams the UK
could face the prospect of planned
blackout this winter If energy supplies
can't be guaranteed the National Grid
say this is unlikely but warned that
millions could lose electricity for
hours if power stations can't get enough
gas to run with 50 of the UK's gas
coming from abroad Thailand's government
says the mass shooting in a nursery
there has caused grief to the entire
nation 22 children are among at least 38
people to have been murdered by a former
policeman who then killed himself and
his wife and child and Prince Harry and
Sir Elton John are among a group of
influential figures suing the publisher
of the Daily Mail alleging they've been
victims of a host of abhorrent criminal
activity the publisher denies what it
calls Preposterous smears
that's all for now we'll have more
updates after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]